The definition of pipe and filter from Wikipedia is a chain of
processing elements called filters arranged so that the output of
each element is communicated by a pipe to become the input to the next.
Layered architectures according to MSDN,
the Microsoft Developers Network, is the grouping of functionality into
distinct layers that are stacked vertically on top of each other.
Communication between layers is explicit and loosely coupled.
Blackboard architecture, out of the artificial intelligence world,
according to Wikipedia, is a common knowledge base.
Is iter, is iteratively updated by a diverse group of specialist knowledge
sources, starting with a problem specification and ending with a solution.
The object oriented architectural style according to MSDN is the division of
responsibilities into individual reusable and self-sufficient objects each
containing the data and the behavior relevant to the object.
Note that object oriented architectural style is somewhat different than what we
talk about an object oriented program or object oriented process for
developing programmers.
Finally, implicit invocation, according to Garland and
Shaw, is a component can broadcast events.
Other components in the system can register interest in those events,
by associating a procedure that should be called when the event is detected.
When the invent is announced by the system, the system itself invokes all of
the procedures that have been registered for the event.